hey I'm Issa Ray I'm shamik Moore and
I'm Haley Steinfeld and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
to me I thought I went back
[Music]
I should be more become Spider-Man I
wrote it in a journal while filming a
movie dope then when the directors and
writers saw the movie dope at Sundance
caught the kid I did my voice note on
the iPhone I sent it over they use it as
a reference for their animation process
and I think they just got used to my
voice and look at that manifestation
where is shamik Moore from
born and raised East Atlanta but my
family is from Jamaica so the body that
you're looking at is completely 100
Jamaican the experience is Atlanta what
movies has Shanique Moore been in I was
in dope I was in this movie called Let
It Snow Pretenders a movie called
Cutthroat City and Spider-Man Into the
spider-verse Now Spiderman across the
spider verse I was gonna say Google it
but that's literally what they're doing
so who is shamik Moore in Wu-Tang I play
Raekwon the chef in Wu-Tang an American
Saga and you ain't seen him make sure
you tap in because it'll change your
perspective and what is shamique Moore
workout routine when I'm on top of it
because right now you know all right so
I wake up we hit the boxing we do boxing
for like an hour and a half two hours
then I do Cross Fitness for an hour and
a half two hours that's up until 1pm so
then we go into meetings and auditions
that's discipline yeah nice thank you
all right how Issa Rae built the world
of insecure
um
just it's my life and my friend's lives
so I'm a thief Ed had amazing writers
shout out to Tara writing staff who does
Issa Ray play in
I play a Barbie
who's the president that's all I can say
what listen I cannot wait
oh can you see me speak French oh
oh yeah
you know wow I'm so jealous does Issa
Rae own a Hilltop I co-owned a coffee
shop called Hilltop in LA right now and
we have four locations oh my God how
cool I like to write in coffee shops
did Haley Steinfeld wear contacts for
Hawkeye I did gray to make my light
brown eyes blue I did that because she
has blue eyes in the comics and I was
told that I might regret the decision a
few days in and I will tell you
there is a thing called CGI that they
use a lot in those types of things you
might just want them to just pop in some
blue eyes for you at the end of the day
because that was that was tough does
Haley Steinfeld play League of Legends
League of Legends I do not it's a it's a
game that's so loved by by so many
people
um except for her well that's not true I
appreciate it I have a lot of respect
for those involved um that have created
it and I feel very lucky that I get to
be a part of the world of League of
Legends Haley Steinfeld water bottle why
are you looking at me like that I want
to know what you got to do with this
water bottle uh so I I used to carry a
gallon of water around now I just carry
the tall bottle of core hydration does
Haley Steinfeld have a middle name wrong
answers only it's on Wikipedia check it
out
is Haley Steinfeld going to be in Marvel
movies that's a question that I Google
that's a question I'm looking for the
answer to your agent wrote that yeah
right great
whoa that was awfully close to me I was
very scary Spiderman across the
spider-verse villain why don't you watch
the movie
[Applause]
yeah yeah that's Inglewood for your kids
Spider-Man across the spider verse suit
there are so many suits I mean miles he
takes pride in creating his own new suit
with the red stripe down the down the
armpit we ain't got to update right with
couple upgrades got some new kicks this
time around given to her actually by
another we didn't need that spider
person who also has a really cool suit
this is about Glenn and Miles yeah
you'll know what I'm talking about if
he's
deep is dead uh Spider-Man across the
spider verse album oh Metro
yeah make sure I don't trust you hey
shout out to Metro boom man who is
Spider-Man 2099 in spider verse who is
he Miguel O'Hara hey AKA Oscar Isaac
yeah spider-verse Jordan one the coolest
did you get schwares there's some new
ones that came out but you see we got
the OG you know the Saucy the sausage
can I get one or can you get one it's
only for people that was in the first
movie no you got that because you in the
second one you was in the first one just
in another dimension
you know
shamik Moore live action Spider-Man I've
seen him in an animated form what's up
with the live action yeah I like all
that energy it's there if you want it if
you can conceive it we can achieve it
more do karate I can do something like
karate which is which is I'm a boxer
I've been boxing for like seven or eight
years now you know I did Muay Thai it's
not karate but self-defense for sure
can shamik Moore sing I can do a little
something that's for sure he can sing
can you just sing like two lines like
literally a little something
um
to make more look alike congratulations
[Laughter]
we're going what what degree
does Easter I have I have a degree in
African and African-American studies
from Stanford University oh excuse me go
off okay what is Issa Ray known for this
is the same person that Googled it yeah
it's very sweet it's the equivalent of
why should I know you why not trying to
help them out um is it no I didn't watch
that that actually just happened to me
it was like but you throw out a
suggestions
that is awkward I was stuck in line and
I was like you're helping me board my
flight so let me just help you I'm going
to see you um I'm probably most known
for my series insecure on HBO what has
Issa right produced I have produced a
number of things series for the internet
series for television there is actually
a show on HBO that we rebooted called
project green light and it's basically
about the act of filmmaking
what is Issa Ray's zodiac sign maybe I'm
a Capricorn oh I love a Capricorn what
are you I'm a sad I love science yes I
love sizes but y'all's tongues oh you no
not like that
like that you literally gave me no no no
no no you guys have sex sharp tongues
when people come at you by the way I so
do that
I was like I know yeah I know it okay
yes okay
oh no no what happened to Issa Ray
huh I die it sounds like something might
have happened what happened to me am I
not here what are you what are you
curious about whoa
whoa said oh no
what is Haley steinfeld's most famous
for I really just get
are you there
I think they know but they're going to
figure it out later so they're going to
get the pick while they're there if
anyone knows me it's because I get to do
what I love so I guess you could say I'm
I'm famous for doing what I love we love
that answer
political politician give her the whoa
what are hailee Steinfeld fans called
Stein vans
[Laughter]
whatever you want to be called You're
you got it what is coast by Halestorm
about simply just wanting to take a
drive on the coast that's all okay it
you really shouldn't think it's about
anything else when you listen to it what
perfume does Haley Steinfeld wear Miss
Dior actually
we're in the clear we're in the clear